Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. zdravo and welcome to the rest is history now you may be wondering why i welcomed you in serbian and the answer tom is that we have reached the balkan republic in a survey of the countries that have qualified for this year's World Cup in Qatar. You chose to do Serbia. You were very keen to do it. Yeah, I was.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。zdravo，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。现在你可能在想，我为什么用塞尔维亚语向你问好。答案是，汤姆，在我们盘点今年卡塔尔世界杯入围国家时，我们来到了巴尔干共和国。你选择了讲塞尔维亚。你对讲这个非常热情。是的，我是。
I would have liked to have done it, but you chose to do it. What would you have chosen to do? Oh. Something involving 20th century coups. I might have chosen the Black Hand, but do you know what, Tom? I'd probably have chosen the Battle of Kosovo-Polye. Okay. The Field of the Blackbirds.
我其实挺想讲的，但你选了。你会选讲什么呢？哦。某个涉及20世纪政变的事情。我可能会选黑手党，但你知道吗，汤姆？我大概会选科索沃波列战役。好的。百灵鸟之原。
That's probably what I'd have chosen. Okay. You're looking deflated with me saying that. No at all not at all not at all so we we obviously before recording episodes we have discussed haven't we what we're going to do yeah so i think i ended up choosing uh stefan dushan the great 14th century serbian emperor yeah which is what you may be expecting me to do. That is what I'm expecting you to do. I'm not going to. Oh, no. I'm ambushing you. I was really looking forward to that, Tom.
我大概会选那个。好吧。看我这么说，你显得有点泄气。完全没有，完全没有，完全没有。所以我们显然在录制节目之前讨论过，不是吗？我们要讲什么。对，所以我想我最后选了——呃——14世纪伟大的塞尔维亚皇帝斯特凡·杜尚。对，这可能也是你期望我选的。这确实是我期望你选的。我不打算讲这个。哦，不。你在设局埋伏我。我真的很期待那个，汤姆。
No. I was really looking forward to it. I've got a totally new one. And the thing that will really excite you about this is that it's prehistory. Oh, for Christ's sake. You love a bit of prehistory, don't you? It's not science. It's prehistory.
不。我真的很期待它。我准备了一个全新的。而最让你兴奋的一点是，它是史前史。哦，看在上帝的份上。你最喜欢史前史了，不是吗？这不是科学。这是史前史。
Oh, for goodness sake. I look at your little face lighting up with joy. But, Dominic. Yeah, I want that. This is actually brilliant yeah this is brilliant i think and i'd be interested to see whether you agree okay because basically where would you say the first script the first written language originated you might say sumeria you might say mesopotamia you might say i'd probably say near niche or novi sad somewhere like that in serbia you'd be right or would you because there is a possibility that the birthplace of written scripts was serbia okay and that serbia was the home of one of the original great civilizations did you
哦，看在上帝的份上。我看着你那张洋溢着喜悦的小脸。但是，多米尼克。是的，我就要这个。这其实太棒了，真的，这太棒了，我想，而且我很想知道你同不同意。好吧？因为基本上，你认为第一个文字、第一种书面语言起源于哪里？你可能会说是苏美尔，你可能会说是美索不达米亚，你可能会说——我大概会说在尼什或诺维萨德附近，塞尔维亚的某个地方。你猜怎么着，或者真的是这样吗？因为存在这样一种可能，书面文字的发源地其实是塞尔维亚。好吧？而且塞尔维亚曾是最初的伟大文明之一的发源地。你
know that no i've never heard that claim made before a place of of urban settlements the first place to develop copper smelting, the first place to develop copper smelting, perhaps the first place to develop a written language. It's amazing, isn't it? Yeah. It's not the kind of thing that's generally known. Tom, you've got a bit of work to do to convince me, I'll be frank with you. Well, it has to be said that it is much debated. But I think this is a genuinely unexpected... I mean, I hadn't realised this at all. And so I was reading through about Serbian history and came across this and thought,
知道吗？不知道，我以前从来没听人这么说过。这是一个有城市聚落的地方，是第一个发展出铜冶炼技术的地方，第一个发展出铜冶炼技术的地方，也许还是第一个发展出书面语言的地方。这太神奇了，不是吗？是的。这不是那种广为人知的事情。汤姆，说实话，你还得花不少功夫才能说服我。嗯，必须得说，这确实充满争议。但我认为这是一个真正意料之外的……我的意思是，我以前完全没意识到这一点。所以我在阅读有关塞尔维亚历史的资料时偶然发现了这个，然后我想，
actually, this is much more interesting. So I had visited a Serbian history podcast, either involving men with revolvers shooting archduchesses or just a lot of scimitars and the Ottomans lurking in the background. But what you didn't expect was Serbia as the birthplace of the first great European civilisation. So Serbian listeners are very strong following in Serbia.
实际上，这要有趣得多。我原本以为会看到一个关于塞尔维亚历史的播客，不是讲拿着左轮手枪射杀大公夫妇的男人，就是一堆弯刀和潜伏在背景里的奥斯曼人。但你没想到的是，塞尔维亚竟然是欧洲第一个伟大文明的发源地。所以塞尔维亚的听众们——我们在塞尔维亚有很强的听众基础。
They'll be delighted by this, Tom. By and large, the Serbian take on this is at the stronger end of arguing that this is the birthplace of civilization. The others are more skeptical. However, so this story begins with a guy called Milhe Vasic. And I hope that I've pronounced his name right. He was a very very long-lived bloke he was born in 1869 and he died in 1956 and so he lived through quite a lot of change yeah so he lived through the collapse of the austria-hungarian uh empire first world war
他们一定会为此高兴的，汤姆。总的来说，塞尔维亚人对这一说法的态度倾向于比较坚定地认为这里是文明的发源地。其他人则更为怀疑。不过，这个故事要从一个叫米洛耶·瓦西奇（Miloje Vasić）的人说起。希望我没有念错他的名字。他是一个极其高寿的人，生于1869年，卒于1956年。所以他经历了相当多的变故。是的，他经历了奥匈帝国的崩溃、第一次世界大战
um second world war communist period in in these episodes we've we've touched on characters who might come from tintin books quite a lot haven't we kind of generals who lead coups and that kind of thing people with dark glasses milahay vasich if you imagine professor calculus you would not be far wrong we had a kind of goatee uh he was bald very scholarly and he was serbia's first and greatest archaeologist and this was he was born at a time where there wasn't i think a great tradition of archaeology in serbia and he went to study in germany got his his doctorate there came back to serbia in 1981 and he was both a museum director in belgrade and he ended up professor of archaeology at belgrade university so he's absolutely you know if you want serbian archaeology he is your man and basically he he was so famous and he was he was so
嗯，第二次世界大战、共产主义时期。在这些节目中，我们经常提到一些仿佛出自《丁丁历险记》的角色，不是吗？比如领导政变的那种将军之类的，戴着墨镜的人。米洛耶·瓦西奇，如果你脑补一下向日葵教授（Professor Calculus），你基本上就猜得八九不离十了。他留着那种山羊胡，谢顶，极具学者风范。他是塞尔维亚第一位也是最伟大的考古学家。他出生的时候，塞尔维亚似乎还没有什么伟大的考古学传统，他去德国学习并在那里获得了博士学位，1981年回到塞尔维亚（译者注：此处播客原文有误，瓦西奇实际于19世纪末回国），他既是贝尔格莱德博物馆的馆长，后来又成了贝尔格莱德大学的考古学教授。所以他绝对是——如果你想了解塞尔维亚考古学，找他准没错。基本上，他太出名了，而且在塞尔维亚考古界举足轻重，以至于通过各种方式，他一直任职到86岁。而且他经历了一次又一次的政权更迭都挺了过来。是的，所以不管是谁掌权，
much the big man in serbian archaeology that in various ways he was in post until he was 86 and he's and he just kept surviving all these regime changes yeah so it didn't matter you know who was in charge. He was the guy who would be going off and doing his excavations. And he is most famous for excavations at a particular village called Vinca, which is just outside Belgrade. And it's now been basically swallowed up by Belgrade. So it's a kind of suburb now and the focus of his excavations was um a great mound about 12 meters high uh called bello brudo again i hope my
他都是那个会去进行考古发掘的人。他最著名的成就是在温察（Vinca）这个位于贝尔格莱德郊外的小村庄进行的考古发掘。现在这个地方基本上已经被贝尔格莱德吞并了，所以它现在算是一个郊区。他发掘的重点是一个大约12米高的大土丘，叫做贝洛布尔多（Bello Brudo）。再次说明，希望我的
pronunciation is right dominic you could help me on that is that is that right uh is that is that i think you just have to say it and yeah i think you know i don't i don't know anything tom i mean i'm just pretending but well you you would know you'd recognize that that is in English, the White Hill. Yeah. And on the surface, there were remnants of kind of a medieval settlement. So he knew that it was a medieval settlement. But he also suspected that it was a tell. And a tell, it's a word that comes from Near Eastern archaeology.
发音没错，多米尼克，你可以在这方面帮帮我。那是……那是……对吗？我，我觉得你只要说出来就行了，对，我觉得，我什么都不知道，汤姆。我的意思是，我只是在装懂。好吧，你肯定能认出来，在英语里这就是“白山”（The White Hill）。是的。而在表面上，有一些中世纪定居点的遗迹。所以他知道这是一个中世纪定居点。但他也怀疑这是一个台形遗址（tell）。“台形遗址”这个词源自近东考古学。
And basically, it's a description of a hill that is just nonstop human settlement. So basically, you dig down and down and down and the whole way through, it's just kind of human rubbish. And so he wanted to know, well, you know, how far can I get down through all this kind of, you know, this layer after layer of cultural debris? And he begins work in 1908, and it gets obviously interrupted by the First World War. So that's bad. And then after the war, the government of Yugoslavia emerges, and it's too skint to basically fund his excavations. He has a brief spell in 1924.
基本上，它是指一个完全由人类连续定居形成的土丘。所以基本上，你往下挖、往下挖、往下挖，整个过程中全都是人类的生活垃圾。所以他想知道，好吧，（我）到底能穿透所有这些文化残余的层层堆积挖多深呢？他在1908年开始工作，但显然被第一次世界大战打断了。所以这很糟糕。战后，南斯拉夫政府成立了，但它太穷了，根本没钱资助他的发掘。他在1924年有过短暂的挖掘期。
But then, because word is getting out internationally that the finds that he's making as he goes further and 1929 through to 1931, and the excavations there continue to this day. And what has provoked the interest of these businessmen in Britain is the fact that he has discovered traces of an incredibly sophisticated civilization right at the bottom of this huge great mound. And what he's found so he's found all kinds of fascinating things he's found ceramics with very complex decorations kind of swirls and whirls and little symbols so we'll come back to them yeah he's found a lot of sculptural art including over 2000 kind of figurative representations so little figurines and i was looking i was reading a book about about this and in the index uh it's a book on the subject in the index enlisted bears birds death symbol birds ducks frogs gorgons hedgehogs rams the snake goddess
但随后，由于国际上开始流传他在挖掘过程中不断取得的新发现的消息，1929年至1931年，那里的发掘工作一直持续到今天。而引起英国商人们兴趣的是，他在这个巨大土丘的最底部发现了极其复杂的文明痕迹。他发现了什么呢？他发现了各种令人着迷的东西：他发现了带有非常复杂装饰的陶瓷，比如各种漩涡、卷纹和小符号——我们等会儿会回到这些符号上来。是的。他发现了大量的雕塑艺术，包括2000多件具象艺术品，也就是小雕像。我当时正在读一本关于这方面的书，在索引中——这是一本关于这个主题的书，在索引中列出了：熊、鸟、死亡符号、鸟类、鸭子、青蛙、蛇发女妖、刺猬、公羊、蛇女神、
spirals stream motifs and vulvas so there there are little kind of clay images of all those things. Okay. I'm not going to dwell on some of those. I'm not a massive prehistory person, but that is an extraordinary collection of finding. Absolutely. I'm glad you agree. And once this has been found, people start looking elsewhere and they find kind of, you know, at this layer, similar trace elements elsewhere and they find kind of you know at this layer similar trace elements and they find for instance evidence of copper smelting and they find houses some of which contain two or three rooms and streets and all these settlements are that they're centered on serbia that the ark of them reaches northwards of serbia and southwards down to the aegean um they're all by rivers they're generally 20 or so acres and the largest have populations up to about 4 000 so you know
螺旋纹、溪流图案和女性外阴——所以有所有这些东西的小型黏土塑像。好吧。我不想在其中一些上面过多停留。我不是一个狂热的史前史爱好者，但那确实是一个非凡的发现合集。绝对是的。很高兴你同意。一旦发现了这些，人们便开始在其他地方寻找，并且他们发现，在这个层面上，其他地方也有类似的微量元素——并且他们发现，在这个层面上，其他地方也有类似的微量元素，比如他们发现了铜冶炼的证据，他们发现了房屋（其中一些包含两到三个房间）和街道。所有这些聚落，它们的中心都在塞尔维亚，它们的分布范围向北延伸到塞尔维亚以北，向南延伸到爱琴海。它们都位于河流旁边，面积通常在20英亩左右，最大的聚落人口可达4000人左右。所以，你知道的，
pretty substantial pretty substantial i mean that is substantial yeah that's a that's a town i mean that's a sizable town but well i don't know what time period we're talking well so that's the question that is the exactly the question so when um vask is excavating in the 20s and the 30s, this is before carbon dating has been developed. So there's no way of precisely dating them. The only way you can do it is through stratigraphy. So that's the key thing about these mounds with the different layers. You can kind of work it out from that way. So you dig through the medieval layers, the classical layers, and then you're going down. But it's an open question really when these are. And essentially the best way to do it is to work out, well, are there, you know, say the pottery, do they resemble pots that you might find elsewhere that are more conclusively dated? So Vasek, when he is, you know, he's chiefly got British backers. So he writes an article in 1930 in the Illustrated London News, and he claims that what he has found is a center of Aegean civilization in the second millennium BC.
相当可观，相当可观。我的意思是，这很可观。是的，那是一个镇子，我的意思是，那是一个相当大的镇子。不过，好吧，我不知道我们说的是什么时期。嗯，这就是问题所在。这正是问题的关键。所以，当瓦西奇在20世纪20年代和30年代进行发掘时，这是在放射性碳测年法（碳14测年）被发明之前。所以当时没有办法对它们进行精确测年。唯一的方法是通过地层学。所以这就是这些带有不同地层的土丘的关键所在。你可以通过这种方式大致推算出来。所以你向下挖掘中世纪层、古典层，然后继续向下。但关于这些遗址究竟属于什么时期，实际上是一个悬而未决的问题。基本上最好的方法是弄清楚，比如，这些陶器，它们是否类似于在其他地方发现的、年代更有定论的陶器？所以当瓦西奇——他主要得到了英国资助者的支持。所以在1930年，他在《伦敦新闻画报》（Illustrated London News）上发表了一篇文章，他声称自己发现的是公元前第二千纪爱琴海文明的一个中心。
And he points out as evidence for this, that the ceramic ware that he has found in his site in Vinca bears similarities to ceramic ware in the earliest layers of Troy. So he's saying kind of, you know, 1500 BC. And his assumption is that this is an Anatolian settlement, that the people who were responsible for building Troy, that they've kind of spread westwards and colonized Serbia and built these settlements. And this is what it's evidence for. Over the course of his life, he changes his mind about this because he is unsettled by the
作为证据，他指出他在温察遗址发现的陶器与特洛伊（Troy）最底层发现的陶器有相似之处。所以他的意思是，大约公元前1500年。他的假设这是一个安纳托利亚（Anatolian）聚落，建造特洛伊的那群人向西扩散，殖民了塞尔维亚并建立了这些定居点。这就是证据所在。在他的余生中，他改变了对这一点的看法，因为他被自己发现的东西的
sophistication of what he's found. And he ends up thinking that actually this is a Greek colony, 7th or 6th century BC. And one of the reasons why he comes to this conclusion is that the people who are making these figurines are absolutely obsessed by masks. So again and again, you get these kind of portraits of humans, but they're obviously wearing masks. And the effect is very, very unsettling. So you might have a head with an obviously female hairdo, but a male face. And that's because she is wearing a mask. There are masks that look very, very like the kind of aliens that you get at Roswell. So if you think of the kind of things in the X-Files or whatever, they look very, very similar.
复杂性感到了不安。他最终认为，实际上这是一个公元前7世纪或6世纪的希腊殖民地。他得出这个结论的原因之一是，制作这些小雕像的人对面具极其着迷。所以你会一次又一次地看到这种人类肖像，但它们显然戴着面具。这种效果非常非常令人不安。所以你可能会看到一个顶着明显女性发型但长着男性面孔的头部。那是因为她戴着面具。有些面具看起来非常非常像罗斯威尔（Roswell）事件里那种外星人。所以如果你想起《X档案》或者诸如此类东西里的形象，它们看起来非常非常相似。
You get animal masks with horns, with kind of ears ears or whatever a lot of them imitate birds so they're very very very weird and i think that vasich is intrigued with the parallels of the masks that you find on minoan creed yeah and then of course you get masks in thethenian tragedy and so he's thinking these are hellenic probably can i Can I jump in, Tom? Yeah. So he published that article in the Illustrated London News in 1930. Yeah. And that's a point where, just think about the political context for his research. Serbia is the dominant partner in the new, what becomes the Yugoslav kingdom, kingdom of Serbs, Croats, and Slovenes as it becomes. I mean, famously, like all these states in the debris
你会看到带有角的动物面具，带着耳朵或者诸如此类的东西，很多都在模仿鸟类，所以它们非常非常怪异。而且我认为瓦西奇对你在米诺斯克里特岛（Minoan Crete）上发现的面具的相似性很感兴趣。是的，然后你当然会在雅典悲剧里看到面具，所以他认为这些是希腊化时期的，大概是——我能插句话吗，汤姆？可以。所以他在1930年《伦敦新闻画报》上发表了那篇文章。是的。正是在那个时候，想想他研究的政治背景。塞尔维亚是新成立的南斯拉夫王国（后来成为塞族、克罗地亚族和斯洛文尼亚族王国）中的主导伙伴。我的意思是，众所周知，就像奥地利和奥斯曼帝国废墟中的所有这些国家一样，它们都极具民族主义色彩。但你可以明白为什么这在英国会很受欢迎，因为当然，英国曾是塞尔维亚在第一次世界大战中的盟友。所以任何能抬高塞尔维亚的事物，都会有一种感伤的吸引力。但随后他提出了这样的论点：首先，这是安纳托利亚的，然后是后来的。这让我感到意外，因为我本以为他会说，“哦，这是某种本土的塞尔维亚传统，我们才是真正的继承者。”所以他是一位享有国际声誉的学者。是的。他在遵循最佳实践。
of the ottoman australian empires very very nationalistic but you could see why it would play well in britain because of course britain had been serbia's ally in world war one so something that bigs up serbia would it would have a kind of sentimental appeal but then he has the argument first of all this anatolian and then later. And that sort of – that surprises me because I would have thought he would say, oh, this is some sort of indigenous Serbian tradition to which we are really the heirs. So he's a scholar with an international reputation. Yeah. And he is doing best practice.
所以他并不是在说“我们在塞尔维亚发现了这个，因此它必定是塞尔维亚的”。我认为他对那个时代的知识潮流保持着警觉。这在很大程度上是一个这样的时期——我的意思是，这是一个基本上正确的假设，即许多文化，包括最明显的农业，都是从近东出发，通过安纳托利亚迁徙到欧洲的定居者带来的。所以他（的观点）是当时的标准解释。是的，而且我认为他倾向于希腊说，只是因为他认识到可能存在与希腊文化的联系。所以这似乎是最明显的解释。好吧。行吧。
So he's not saying we found this in Serbia, therefore it must be Serbian. I think he's alert to the intellectual trends of the age. And this is very much a period, you know, I mean, it's an assumption that is basically true that a lot of culture, including most obviously agriculture, has come from settlers moving out of the near east through anatolia into europe um and so he's you know this is kind of standard explanation at the time yeah and i think that you know he's he's going with with the greek thing is just because he's you know he's recognizing that there are possible links to Greek culture. And so this seems the obvious explanation. Okay. All right.
我的意思是，他不是一个公开的民族主义学者。我的意思是，他是一个骄傲的塞尔维亚人，但他乐于顺从他所看到的证据。是的。但随后放射性碳测年法出现了，而碳14测年法揭示了一个惊人的事实，那就是这个遗址有7000年的历史。多么戏剧性的反转！
I mean, he's not an overtly nationalist scholar. I mean, he's a proud Serbian, but he's happy to go with what he sees as the evidence. Yeah. But then the radiocarbon dating comes in, and the radiocarbon dating reveals something amazing, which is that this staff is 7,000 years old. What a twist.
这是我没料到的。所以温察文化——后来人们这样称呼它，是以他发掘的这个村庄命名的，但它的范围相当广泛，不仅涵盖塞尔维亚大部，还延伸到了罗马尼亚和保加利亚。这些定居点的年代可以追溯到公元前5700年至公元前4200年。所以这是一个半千纪、不断走向复杂的文化。这意味着，在那个时代的背景下，其启示是惊人的，因为这意味着这比特洛伊还要早。这比——比希腊人还要早。
That I did not expect. So the Vinca culture, as it comes to be called, named after this village that he's excavated, but which covers quite a broad spread of Serbia and beyond into Romania and Bulgaria as well. These settlements can be dated from 5,700 to 4,200 BC. So that's a millennium and a half of increasingly sophisticated culture. And the implication of that is astounding, basically, in the context of the age, because this implies that this is earlier than, say, Troy. It's earlier than- Earlier than the Greeks.
绝对比希腊人早。更早，绝对比希腊人早得多，比希腊人早得多，而且也比苏美尔文明的全盛时期更早，比埃及法老文明的出现要早得多。所以真的、真的很出乎意料。而且这些元素绝对具备某种原初文明的特征，就像定义了美索不达米亚或埃及等河流文明的那种特征。所以你拥有非常非常集约化的农业，所有这些聚落都位于河流边缘。它们似乎在那里定居，与其说是为了丰富的猎物——这些可不是那种四处游荡的狩猎采集者，而是那些在农业资源丰富的地区定居下来的人。正因为如此，虽然从未发现过犁，但人们普遍认为他们一定拥有犁。
Definitely earlier than the Greeks. Earlier, definitely earlier than the Greeks, way, way earlier than the Greeks, but also earlier than the heyday of the Sumerian civilization, much earlier than the emergence of Pharaonic civilization in Egypt. So really, really unexpected. And the elements are definitely those of a kind of proto-civilization, of the kind that define the riverine civilizations of Mesopotamia or Egypt, say. So you have very, very intensive agriculture and all these settlements, they're on the edge of rivers. They seem to have been settled there, not so much because there's good game. These are not kind of wandering hunter-gatherers. These are people who are settling in places that are agriculturally rich. So because of that, no plough has ever been found, but it is all pretty universally accepted that they must have had ploughs. parley they they introduce wheat they're planting flax which they are using to manufacture uh
他们引入了小麦，种植用于制造服装的亚麻。而这反过来——正如后来在美索不达米亚和埃及发生的那样——产生了农业剩余，这反过来似乎使得这些规模相当大的聚落得以发展出市场和城镇。那么想必，既然你有了城镇和市场，你肯定得有某种权威，比如国王？我们马上会讲到。我们待会儿会讲到。在某些定居点附近，还建有靠近铜矿脉的地方。所以有了工业的证据。在塞尔维亚北部有一个叫普洛奇尼克（Plochnik）的地方，它实际上是在1927年修建铁路线时首次被发现的。但直到1996年才进行了认真的考古发掘。
clothing and this in turn the you know as will happen later in mesopotamia and egypt this generates agricultural surplus which in turn seems to have enabled these really quite large settlements to grow markets and towns and presumably then if you've got towns and you've got markets you must have some sort of authority, kings? We'll come to that. We will come to that. You also have, in certain settlements, have been built close to seams of copper ore. So evidence for industry. So there's a place called Plochnik in northern Serbia, which was actually first discovered in 1927 when they're developing a railway. But it's only excavated serious excavations in 1996.
所以这些都是相当近期的发现，而且仍在进行中。在2008年，他们发现了一把铜斧，其年代可追溯到公元前5500年。在罗德尼克山（Rodnik Mountain）还有一个叫贝洛沃德（Belovode）的遗址，据说位于塞尔维亚中部。我对塞尔维亚地理没有那么熟悉。不得不说，你应付得游刃有余。他们在那里发现的是世界上最古老、年代最确凿的铜冶炼证据。哇。
So these are quite recent and ongoing. And in 2008, they discover a copper axe, which is dated to 5,500 BC. And there's a site, Belovode, in the Rodnik Mountain, which apparently is in central Serbia. I'm not sufficiently familiar with Serbian geography. You're carrying it off with great aplomb, I have to say. And what they find there is the world's oldest securely dated evidence of copper smelting. Wow.
所以这是一个正在进入铜器时代的石器时代（新石器时代）文明。据我们从考古证据中了解到的，它似乎是第一个做到这一点的文化。所以这是在迈入金属时代，而且这一切都发生在塞尔维亚。这已经够壮观了。是的。但所有可能性中最戏剧性的是，温察文化——这个出人意料的文明——可能已经发展出了文字。因为其中许多遗址——我提到温察本身有陶瓷、小雕像，它们上面装饰着各种各样的符号。但这些符号开始在塞尔维亚及其他地区的遗址中被发现。
So this is a Neolithic civilization that is entering the copper age. And it seems, as far as we can tell from the archaeological evidence, to be the first culture anywhere that does this. So this is entering the age of metal and it's happening in Serbia. So that's spectacular enough. Yeah. But the most dramatic possibility of all is that the Vinca culture, this unexpected civilization civilization that it might have developed writing. Because lots of these sites, I mentioned that Vinca itself has the ceramics, the figurines, they're decorated with all kinds of symbols. But these start to be found in sites across Serbia and beyond.
它们中的许多似乎是动物的象形图。所以，你知道的，有点像汉字、象形文字，或者我们使用的字母，你可以把它们追溯到牛头的画像等等。所以有这些，还有卐字形、十字形、V形符号。总共有大约五千五百个这些不同的符号。所以人们开始好奇：它们代表什么？而20世纪60年代在一个叫塔塔里亚（Tartaria）的村庄的一项发现，让这个问题得到了极大的推动。遗憾的是，对于塞尔维亚听众来说，这个村庄实际上不在塞尔维亚，而是在罗马尼亚，但这是一个非常惊人的发现。那是三块小泥板，上面密密麻麻地刻满了这些温察符号。
And lots of them seem to be pictograms of animals so um you know rather in the way that say chinese script or hieroglyphs or indeed actually the alphabet that we use you can trace them back to um you know portraits of ox's heads or whatever so there's that uh there are swastikas there are crosses there are chevrons and in all there are about five and a half thousand of these different symbols and so people started wondering what do they represent? And that question is turbocharged by a find that is made in 1961 in a village called Tataria, which I'm afraid for Serbian listeners isn't actually in Serbia, it's in Romania, but very amazing find. And it's three small tablets, which are just covered with these kind of venture symbols.
我们就把它们叫做温察符号吧。它们似乎以某种看起来像文字的形式排列着。其中两块泥板是长方形的，一块是圆形的。哦，天哪，汤姆。我刚刚谷歌了一下它们。它们太惊人了。它们真的很惊人，不是吗？
We'll call them the venture symbols. And they seem to be arrayed in what looks like a form of writing. And two of these tablets are rectangular. One is round. Oh, my God, Tom. I've just Googled them. They're amazing. They are amazing, aren't they?
所以你可以看出来。其中一块长方形的泥板——圆形的那块上面钻了孔。没钻孔的那块——上面钻了孔的那块，上面有一个带角的动物插图。当它们被发现时，它们是未烧制的。所以发现它们的人下令将它们烧制以保存下来。这样做的问题在于，这个过程会阻止碳14测年。所以它们无法进行碳测年。但它的地层学关系相当明确。它们是在一个指向公元前5500年左右的地层中被发现的。
So you can see. So one of the rectangular ones, the round one has holes drilled through it. The one that doesn't have has holes drilled through it. The one that doesn't have a hole drilled through it has an illustration of a horned animal. Now, when they're found, they're unbaked. And so what the guy who does it orders is that they should be baked to preserve them. The problem with that is that this process prevents carbon dating. So they can't be carbon dated. But the stratigraphy of it is pretty clear. They have been found at a layer that points to a date of about 5,500 BC.
所以大约与这把铜斧制造的时期相同。而这些比苏美尔楔形文字、埃及象形文字早了大约2000年。所以再次说明，这简直令人匪夷所思。然而，围绕它们的争议也很多。哦，我想我们大概应该在这个时候休息一下。等我回来时，我会讨论这些争议。汤姆，我有一种不祥的预感，这又是你有时会做的那种播客：你讲了20分钟，非常令人兴奋，然后我们休息一下，你回来后说“但是——”不，不，它们确实非常神秘，而且围绕它们有很多争论。好吧，休息回来后看看汤姆到底会不会来个“但是”，还是说情况依然——有一个“但是”，但我觉得这不是一个绝对确凿的“但是”。好的，太棒了。休息一下，回来听听那个不那么绝对确凿的“但是”。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
So around the same time as this copper axe is being manufactured. And these predate Sumerian cuneiform, Egyptian hieroglyphs by about 2 000 years so again i mean this is stupefying yeah however a lot of controversy surrounds them oh and i think that we should probably take a break at this point so when i come back i will discuss the controversies i have the nasty feeling tom this is one of those podcasts that you do sometimes where you talk for 20 minutes and it's very exciting then we take a break and you come back and you say but well no no they are genuinely mysterious and there is there is a lot of debate around them well come back after the break and see if tom does do one of his butts or whether it's still as there is a but there is a
如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并抢先获得现场门票，请访问 theredisentertainment.com，网址是 theredisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。汤姆一直在引导我们了解塞尔维亚温察文化这个极其神秘的故事，这是由考古学家米洛耶·瓦西奇发现的。汤姆，你在上半场结束时给我们留下了悬念，谈到了这些泥板的发现，人们认为这是文字，是早于苏美尔或埃及文化的文明，这一切都在塞尔维亚爆发。然后你以一个“然而”结束了上半场。
but i think it's not an absolutely conclusive but. OK, excellent. Come back after the break for a not absolutely conclusive but. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
所以这到底是怎么回事？是的。让我们具体聚焦于来自塔塔里亚村的这些泥板，这些符号似乎在形成某种文字。所以这些泥板周围存在争议。我在上半场提到，这些泥板为了保存而被烧制了。这样做带来的影响是无法对它们进行碳14测年。人们认为这很可疑。我的意思是，碳14测年非常重要。而且可能存在某种问题。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment dot com that's the rest is entertainment dot com welcome back to the rest is history tom has been guiding us through this extraordinarily mysterious story of the Vinca culture in Serbia, found by the archaeologist Miloje Vazic. And Tom, you left us sort of hanging at the end of the first half, talking about the discovery of these tablets, the sense that this is writing, this is civilization that predates the Sumerian culture or Egyptian, and it all kicked off in Serbia. And then you sort of ended with talk of a however.
有人认为，如果它们是真实的，如果它们确实来自公元前5500年，那么它们或许带有苏美尔原初楔形文字的印记。因为正是在公元前5500年左右，美索不达米亚正在发展出这类符号，所以也许存在某种联系。有人认为，也许它们在考古发掘中被搞混了，实际上来自更高的地层。所以，好吧，也许它们被搞混了。还有人认为它们纯粹是伪造的。所以对此并没有真正的共识——是由……伪造的，但它们来自罗马尼亚而不是塞尔维亚，所以它们不可能是由塞尔维亚民族主义者伪造的之类的，但它们可能是由罗马尼亚民族主义者或其他人伪造的。对，我认为这是一个非常开放的问题。但即使——你看，即使我们把它们放在一边，说它们没有被确凿证实——尽管许许多多的考古学家和学者确实承认它们是真实的，也有很多人承认它们是真实的——它们是文字吗？因为它们可能是各种各样的事物，因为它们给了人们某种感觉。我的意思是，你之前谈到过它们：一个是圆形的，两个是长方形的。它们有点像——上面有一张看起来像山羊的图片，有几张坦率地说看起来像凳子或马桶的图片，有卐字形、十字形、还有各种相当明显的符号。
So what's going on? Yes. So focus specifically on these tablets from the village of Tartaria, where these symbols, they seem to be forming a kind of writing. So there is controversy around the tablets. I mentioned in the first half that these got baked supposedly to preserve them. And the effect of that is that you can't carbon date it. And people have argued that this is suspicious. I mean, the carbon dating, it's so important to carbon date them. And it's possible that there's a problem with that.
是的，但问题是，我们只是缺乏能够让学者对它们进行评估并得出确定结论的语境。所以我们没有罗塞塔石碑（Rosetta Stone）的同类物，显然，因为这些比任何可辨识的书写系统都要早大约2000年。所以它们可能是装饰品、所有权标记，或者是某种早期文字的雏形。部分问题在于，它们可能是文字雏形的这种想法，在双方阵营中都引发了极其强烈的激情。总的来说，塞尔维亚民族主义者非常热衷于这种观点，即塞尔维亚确实是最早文字形式的发源地。在绝对疯狂的边缘群体中，甚至有一些人伪造了学者的身份，发表虚假的学术文章等等，争辩说这不仅是一种文字形式，而且实际上还是古塞尔维亚语的一种形式。
People have argued that if they are authentic, if they do come from 5,500 BC, then perhaps they bear the stamp of Sumerian proto-cuneiform. Because this is around 5500 bc these sorts of symbols are being developed in mesopotamia so perhaps there are links people have argued that perhaps it got jumbled up in the excavations and actually it comes from a higher layer so okay yeah perhaps it got confused and there are people who argue that they're straight forgeries so there's no there's no consensus on that really forgeries done by but they were from romania not serbia so they wouldn't have been forged by serbian nationalists or something but they might be forged by romanian
塞尔维亚语？斯拉夫语？绝对是的。当时斯拉夫人甚至还没到巴尔干半岛呢。所以有一位教授，他的一生似乎都是编造出来的。没错。他辩称，不仅在塔塔里亚泥板上发现的这种文字是古塞尔维亚语，伊特鲁里亚语（Etruscan）也是塞尔维亚语的一种形式。因此他写了一篇文章，声称伊特鲁里亚语的词根是斯洛文尼亚语，而且这方面的考古文献证据如此明显，不容忽视。整个故事非常有翁贝托·埃科（Umberto Eco）的风格。我的意思是，这是一个绝佳的故事。它
nationalists or whatever i right i think i think the it's very much kind of open question on that but even you see even if even if we put them to one side and say it's not conclusively proven and lots and lots of archaeologists and scholars do accept that they're authentic there are lots who accept that they're authentic are they writing so there's a whole range of things that they could be because they give people a sense they are I mean you were talking about them before there's one circular two rectangular they are kind of there's a picture of what looks like a goat there's a couple of pictures of frankly what look like stools or toilets there are swastikas there are crosses there are kind of they are kind of quite obvious symbols
看起来不太可能。但绝对有——有一些非常杰出的语言学家对此高度重视。网上有一篇文章，作者是一个叫托比·格里芬（Toby Griffin）的人，他是南伊利诺伊大学的一位语言学家、教授。他从这些符号中推演出鸟、女神和熊的词汇。词汇？我的意思是，我看着这些符号在想……好吧，它们是符号。谁知道实际的词是什么呢？是的。它们是符号，谁知道实际的词是什么呢？是的。但是——但是你可以利用这些符号——
yeah but the problem is is we just don't have the context that would enable scholars to evaluate them and come to a conclusive conclusion. So we don't have the equivalent of a Rosetta Stone, obviously, because these are earlier by about 2000 years ahead of any distinguishable writing system. So they could be, you know, decorations, they could be ownership markings, or they could be some form of early proto-writing. And part of the problem is that the idea that they might be proto-writing generates incredibly intense passions on both sides. So by and large, Serbian nationalists are very, very keen on this idea that Serbia is indeed the birthplace of the earliest form of writing. And there have been kind of on the absolute wacko fringe, there are people who have kind of faked scholarly identities, put out bogus scholarly articles, all kinds of things, arguing that not only is it a form of writing, but it is actually a form of proto-Serbian.
他认为你可以弄清楚——它们会表示什么。所以他写了一句非同寻常的话，他说：“人类语言中已知最古老的句子表述的是……”你想知道人类语言中已知最古老的句子是什么吗？我很想知道，汤姆。“熊女神和鸟女神是——”熊女神。这挺让人失望的，不是吗？好吧，你可能会说这令人失望，但我认为托比·格里芬教授不敢苟同，因为他……我不是在开枪。他只是个信使，汤姆。我没有朝信使开枪。你是在驳倒他。这是他的重大见解。他找到了人类语言中已知最古老的句子，而你在冷嘲热讽。这是我看到的这三块石头里的哪一块？记不清了。我不记得了，我不知道。你不知道，这太令人失望了。我记不清了，我觉得它是两行——是两行带有一条弯曲的线条，是三行带有一条弯曲的线条。是的。但他的观点——你可能还记得，米洛耶·瓦西奇最终认为温察文化来自希腊，它是一个希腊殖民地。是的，格里芬教授再次抓住了与希腊的相似之处——因为他说，好吧，熊女神和鸟女神是什么？他锁定的形象是阿尔忒弥斯（Artemis），
Serbian? The Slavic language? Absolutely. The Slavs weren't even in the Balkans at this point. So there's a professor whose entire career seems to have been invented. Right. And he argues that not only is this script found on the Tartarian tablets, proto-Serbian, that Etruscan also is a form of Serbian. And so he wrote this article in which he claimed the Etruscan word roots are Slovene and the archaeological documentation for this is so obvious that it cannot be overlooked. And the whole story is very, very Umberto Eco. I mean, it's a great story. It
她——与熊有关，她是野兽的女主人。他的论点是，这个句子展望了延续几千年、最终在阿尔忒弥斯形象达到顶峰的神话传统。但这比阿尔忒弥斯早了数千年，对吧，汤姆？确实比这早了数千年。是的。我的意思是，这在我看来是一个巨大的跨越。我的意思是，甚至比关于鸟的那些说法跨越还要大——好吧，你可能会这么觉得，但这是一个由一位非常杰出、备受赞誉的考古学家兼人类学家玛丽娅·吉姆巴塔斯（Marija Gimbutas）提出的论点。你听说过她吗？
seems improbable. But there are absolutely, you know, there are very, very distinguished linguists who take it highly seriously. So there's an article online by a guy called Toby Griffin, who is a professor at Southern Illinois University, a linguist. And he extrapolates from it, from these symbols, words for bird, for goddess, and for bear. Words? I mean, I'm looking at these symbols and thinking. Well, they're symbols. Who knows what the actual word is? Yeah. their symbols who knows what the actual word is yeah but but but you can using the symbols you
是的，我对她的作品非常熟悉。所以——不，我没有告诉过她。所以她很有名。她作为70年代、80年代乃至90年代最著名的女性主义考古学家而闻名。好吧。所以她在战后逃离了苏联占领区，最终落脚于加州伯克利。她非常热衷于这样一种观点，即她所谓的“老欧洲”（Old Europe）的原住民——也就是以塞尔维亚为基地的这个文明——崇拜着一位大地女神（Mother Goddess）。她认为这种老欧洲文化一直延伸到爱琴海，所以爱琴海的岛屿延伸到克里特岛，延伸到西西里岛，而且它本质上是和平的。所以你会问，它拥有什么样的文化？
can work he says you can work out what what well they would denote what these denote and so he has this extraordinary sentence where he says the oldest known sentence in human language states do you want to know the oldest known sentence in human language i'd love to tom the bear goddess and the bird goddess are the bear goddess indeed. It's disappointing, isn't it? Well, you may say disappointing, but I think Professor Toby Griffin would beg to disagree because he... I'm not shooting. He's just the messenger, Tom. I'm not shooting the messenger. You are shooting him down. This is his great insight. He's got the oldest known sentence
似乎没有任何战争的证据。没有武器。没有，它是平等的，以女神为中心的，并且是母权制的。等等，她是一位70年代的女性主义考古学家。她是。而她发现了一些——你知道的——70年代的女性主义考古学家想要发现的东西。是的。
in human language and you're sneering at it. Which stone is this of the three stones I'm looking at? Can't remember. I don't't remember i don't know you don't know that's disappointing i can't remember i think it's two lines it's two lines with it's two lines with a squiggle and it's three lines with a squiggle yeah but he his argument and you may remember that uh that milahave basich ends up arguing that the the vinci culture came from greece that it was a greek colony yeah and again uh professor griffin is seizing on the parallels with greece that it was a greek colony yeah and again uh professor griffin is seizing on the parallels with greece because he's saying okay well what's a a bear goddess and a bit and a bird goddess and he the figure that he fixes on is the figure of artemis
所以她写道，7000年前东南欧的居民并不是新石器时代初期的原始村落。相反，他们发展出了一种独特的文化模式，与安纳托利亚、美索不达米亚、叙利亚、巴勒斯坦和埃及的类似发展同时代。但她的观点是，比任何其他那些后来成为文明巨大发动机的原初文明相比，温察文明——她称之为老欧洲的文明——才是最像加州女性主义嬉皮士的文明，
who um has bears she associates with bears she's the mistress of the beasts and his argument is that this sentence is looking forward to millennia and millennia of mythological tradition that will culminate in the figure of Artemis. This is thousands of years before Artemis though, isn't it, Tom? It is thousands and thousands of years before. Yeah. I mean, that seems a massive stretch to me. I mean, even bigger stretch than the stuff about the bird well you may you may think so but it it is an argument that has been advanced by a very eminent and very celebrated archaeologist and anthropologist called maria gimbutas have you have you heard of
在70年代和80年代。是的。一个学者在过去中找到他们希望在现实中看到的东西，这是多么不同寻常啊。所以显而易见的问题是，嗯——她谈到美索不达米亚或埃及的文明，它们后来成为了著名的文明中心。那么温察文化怎么了？它为什么崩溃了？为什么没人听说过它？它发生了什么？她的论点是，它被印欧人摧毁了。所以印欧人是这样一群人：语言学家已经研究得出，他们是那些传播了最终成为北印度和欧洲语言的语言的人，所以它将包括梵语、古希腊语、拉丁语，而在当代它将包括印地语、意大利语和英语。没错。这是一个巨大的谜团：印欧人是从哪里来的？她认为印欧人基本上来自乌克兰地区，实际上就是乌克兰周围。她认为他们是好战的、父权制的，他们不崇拜大地女神，他们崇拜天空之神。所以是朱庇特、宙斯（Zeus Pater），也就是众神之父、这些专横的天空之神。粗鲁的男人。绝对是一群粗人。
her yeah i'm very familiar with her work so no i I haven't told her. So she is famous. And she's famous as probably the most famous feminist archaeologist of the 70s and 80s and into the 90s. Okay. So she escaped the Russian occupation after the war, ended up in Berkeley in California. And she was a great enthusiast for the idea that the original peoples of what she calls Old Europe. And so this is the civilization based in Serbia that they had worshipped a mother goddess. And she argues that this culture of Old Europe, that it extended as far as the Aegean. So the islands in the Aegean extended as far as Crete, extended as far as Sicily, and that it was essentially peaceful. So you're asking what kind of culture did it have?
粗人。所以你有这样一个和平的母权制文明，有着他们的语言、精美的陶器和所有这些东西。然后这些印欧人骑着马闯入并摧毁了一切。汤姆，我可不想陷入完全的自我讽刺中。我的意思是，坦率地说，这艘船在好几个播客之前就已经开走了。我也不想让自己看起来像个一无所知的悲惨怀疑论者，对史前史一无所知却对一切都大加嘲弄。
There doesn't seem to be any evidence of warfare. There's no weapons. No, that it was egalitarian, that it was goddess-centered, and that it was matriarchal. So hold on, she's a feminist 70s archaeologist. She is. And she's found something that, you know, a 70s feminist archaeologist would want to find. Yes.
似乎没有任何战争的证据。没有武器。不，它是平均主义的，以女神为中心的，而且是母权制的。等等，她是一位70年代的女权主义考古学家。确实是的。她发现了一些70年代女权主义考古学家希望找到的东西。是的。
Yeah. And so she wrote that the inhabitants of Southeastern Europe 7,000 years ago were not the primitive villages of the incipient Neolithic. Instead, they involved a unique cultural pattern, contemporary with similar developments in Anatolia, Mesopotamia, Syria, Palestine, and Egypt. But her argument is that more than any of those other proto-civilizations that will go on to become the great motors of civilization, that the Vinci civilization,
是的。因此她写道，7000年前东南欧的居民并不是早期新石器时代的原始村庄。相反，他们形成了一种独特的文化模式，与安纳托利亚、美索不达米亚、叙利亚、巴勒斯坦和埃及的类似发展同时代。但她的论点是，与那些后来成为文明巨大推动力的其他早期文明相比，温查文明，
the civilization of old Europe, as she calls it, that was the civilization that was most like a feminist hippie in california yeah in the 70s and 80s yeah how unusual for an academic to find in the past what they would like to see in the present so and the obvious question is well you know she talks about civilizations of mesopotamia or egypt they go on to become famous centers of civilization. So what happens to the Vinca culture? Why does it collapse? Why has no one heard of it? What happened to it? And her argument is that it gets destroyed by the Indo-Europeans. So the Indo-Europeans are the people who linguists have worked out are the people who spread the languages that become the languages of northern india and europe so it would include sanskrit would include ancient greek
正如她所称的“老欧洲文明”，那是那个最像70年代和80年代加州女权主义嬉皮士的文明。学者在过去中找到他们希望在现在看到的东西，这是多么不寻常啊。所以显而易见的问题是，她谈到美索不达米亚或埃及的文明时，它们后来成为了著名的文明中心。那么温查文化发生了什么？它为什么崩溃了？为什么没有人听说过它？它发生了什么？她的论点是它被印欧人摧毁了。所以印欧人是语言学家们弄清楚的那群人，他们传播了后来成为北印度和欧洲语言的语言，所以它将包括梵语，将包括古希腊语
would include latin and into the contemporary it would include hindi it would include italian and it would include english right and big mystery where you know where did the india europeans come she argues that the india europeans come from basically the region of Ukraine, actually, around Ukraine. And she argues that they're violent, they're patriarchal, they don't worship mother goddesses, they worship sky gods. So Jupiter, Zeus, Pater, the father's use, the father of, you know, these domineering sky gods. Rough men. Absolute boohis.
将包括拉丁语，在当代它将包括印地语，将包括意大利语，还将包括英语，对吧？这是一个巨大的谜团，印欧人到底来自哪里？她认为印欧人基本上来自乌克兰地区，实际上就在乌克兰周围。她认为他们是暴力的、父权制的，他们不崇拜母亲女神，他们崇拜天空之神。所以朱庇特、宙斯、帕特尔，也就是父亲宙斯，（你知道的）这些专横的天空之神的父亲。粗鲁的男人。绝对的粗人。
Yeah. Boohis. So you have this peaceful, matriarchal civilization with their language and their beautiful pots and all that kind of stuff. And then these Indo-Europeans in there with their horses turn up and destroy everything. Tom, I don't want to lapse into total self-parody. I mean, frankly, that ship has probably sailed many podcasts ago. And nor do I want to appear like I'm just a miserable skeptic who doesn't know anything about prehistoric history and just pouring score on everything.
是的。粗人。所以你有这样一个和平的、母权制的文明，有着他们的语言、美丽的陶罐以及所有这些东西。然后这些带着马匹的印欧人出现并摧毁了一切。汤姆，我不想陷入完全的自我讽刺。我的意思是，坦率地说，这艘船可能在很多期播客之前就已经开走了。我也不想表现得像个只会在史前历史上一窍不通却对一切冷嘲热讽的悲惨怀疑论者。
But that sounds like total tosh to me. It just sounds like complete wish fulfillment. I don't think it's total tosh, but I think that it is a kind of Rorschach test. Yeah. And I think that just as with, you know, forgeries, it takes maybe a few decades before you can recognise the period
但这听起来对我们来说完全是废话。听起来就像完全的一厢情愿。我不认为这是完全的废话，但我觉得这是一种罗夏墨迹测验。是的。而且我认为，就像伪造品一样，可能需要几十年来识别那个时期
where the forgery is painted. So, you know, if you have a Renaissance painting that's forged in the 1920s, you know, it could take you 50 years before you look at it and say, that was clearly painted in the 1920s. I think in a similar way, perhaps with academic fashion, particularly when it's something like prehistory, where the evidence is so sparse. And it can take time, perhaps, for you to see that academic fashions are absolutely reflective of broader cultural and social trends. For the last five minutes, I felt like I'm trapped in a California seminar room in 1974. Well, so today, the consensus among archaeologists about this is what happened to the venture civilization is that they weren't overthrown by a violent invasion. That the Indo-Europeans, when they came,
伪造品被绘制的时期。所以，你知道的，如果你有一个在20世纪20年代伪造的文艺复兴时期的画作，你知道的，可能需要50年你才会看到它并说，那是显然在20世纪20年代画的。我认为以类似的方式，也许对于学术时尚，特别是当它是像史前史这样证据非常稀少的东西时。这可能需要时间，也许让你看到学术时尚绝对反映了更广泛的文化和社会趋势。在过去的五分钟里，我觉得自己被困在1974年加利福尼亚的一个研讨室里。好吧，所以今天，考古学家对此的共识是，关于温查文明发生了什么，是他们没有被暴力入侵推翻。印欧人在他们到来时，
that it was a much more peaceful process of integration. That's all the rage now with academics. Yeah. And also that the civilisation were destroyed by basically environmental degradation. I was just about to say. They exhausted the soils and they wiped out wildlife. Do you know, before you started that sentence,
那是一个更加和平的融合过程。这现在在学术界非常流行。是的。并且该文明基本上是被环境退化所摧毁的。我正要说。他们耗尽了土壤，消灭了野生动物。你知道的，在你开始那句话之前，
I thought to myself, I'll jump in and I'll say, I bet academics now think it was climate change. And of course they do. So the argument is that now that it's climate change or it's environmental degradation, and that there was no violent invasion by immigrants, but that they were peacefully integrated. Kindly multiculturalism. So I'm, who knows? Again, I just don't think that probably that the evidence is there. But again, I suspect that perhaps in 50 years, people will look back and say, well, of course, people in 2020, that's very reflective of, of broader intellectual and cultural opinions. So the great thing about the venture culture then, Tom, is that it's actually a window into changing. Yeah. It's as interesting about, about academia in the 20th and 21st century as it is
我心里想，我会插话并说，我敢打赌现在的学者认为是气候变化。他们当然也这么认为。所以论点是，现在是气候变化或环境退化，并且没有移民的暴力入侵，而是他们被和平融合。友好的多元文化主义。所以我是，谁知道呢？再说一次，我只是不认为证据就在那里。但同样，我怀疑也许在50年里，人们会回过头来说，好吧，当然，2020年的人们，这非常反映了更广泛的知识和文化观点。所以关于温查文化的伟大之处在于，汤姆，它实际上是一扇了解变化的窗户。是的。这关于20和21世纪的学术界，和关于
about, I mean, actually, you know, it's an amazing civilization. I mean, it is incredible. These settlements do exist. The copper smelting did happen. These weird squiggles, you know, it doesn't matter if they're a language or not. I mean, I will put up images from it. It is there, but I just don't think that it would seem that we know enough to arrive at a conclusive opinion either way. We should sort of end the podcast not by talking about academic fashion, but by talking about the civilization itself. So, of course, you're not a sort of card-carrying, massively specialized expert on this. No, I literally found out about it a week ago. Well, that's all you need. I mean, that's all you need. Come on.
我的意思是，事实上，你知道的，这是一个了不起的文明。我的意思是，这真是难以置信。这些定居点确实存在。铜冶炼确实发生了。这些奇怪的曲线，你知道的，它们是不是一种语言并不重要。我的意思是，我会发布它的图片。它就在那里，但我只是不认为我们知道的足够多，无法在任何一种情况下得出结论性的意见。我们应该结束播客，不是通过谈论学术时尚，而是通过谈论文明本身。所以，当然，你不是那种拥有极度专业知识的专家。不，我 буквально 一周前才发现它的。好吧，这就是你所需要的。我的意思是，这就是你所需要的。得了吧。
But what do you think? Because you know a lot about sort of Neolithic stuff and all that. I know that I don't know. I know that I don't know. But what I would say is that... The dates are right. I was really astounded. Yeah.
但你怎么看？因为你对新石器时代之类的东西了解很多。我知道我一无所知。我知道我一无所知。但我要说的是……日期是对的。我真的被震惊了。是的。
I had not expected that. And what also surprises me is that it's not better known. Well, that's astounding, aren't they? I was really astounded. Yeah. I had not expected that. And what also surprises me is that it's not better known. Well, that's astounding, isn't it? That it's not better known. Because this really isn't kind of on the radar. But that's because it's in Serbia, right? So if it was in Britain, in Germany, in France, it'd be a big tourist destination. There'd be a huge visitor centre.
我没有预料到这一点。让我惊讶的是它没有更广为人知。好吧，这很惊人，不是吗？我真的被震惊了。是的。我没有预料到这一点。让我惊讶的是它没有更广为人知。好吧，这很惊人，不是吗？它没有更广为人知。因为这真的不在雷达上。但这因为它在塞尔维亚，对吧？所以如果它在英国、德国、法国，它会是一个巨大的旅游目的地。会有巨大的游客中心。
Well, I think there'd probably be a kind of slightly nationalist strain. Of course there would. Kids would do it in primary school, wouldn't they absolutely would people dress up as members of the vinture yes matrix yeah yes that's the problem you have to it's it's very difficult to extrapolate from the found you know from the remains to being found any sense of what how these function and what happened to them yeah and that's why I think they're vulnerable to kind of trends. But there's also that extraordinary mystery about the disappearance. Because, I mean, for such a civilization so far ahead of its time
好吧，我想可能会有一种稍微带民族主义色彩的倾向。当然会有。孩子们会在小学里学习它，绝对会，人们会打扮成温查的成员，矩阵，是的，是的，这就是问题所在，你必须，很难从发现的遗迹中推断出这些东西是如何运作的以及发生了什么，是的，这就是为什么我认为它们很容易受到各种潮流的影响。但关于它的消失还有一个非同寻常的神秘之处。因为，我的意思是，对于这样一个走在时代前列的文明
to have flourished and then vanished. Okay, so that's one final thing, is that the two leading figures in the study of this, so Milajevasic and Maria Gimbatas, these are the two top names in the field. Both of them are absolutely alert to a feeling that something about this culture ends up being expressed in Minoan and they wipe the floor with the Vinci culture and it all gets obliterated. Her argument is that traces of this survive on islands in the Aegean. So in El Crete, in the Cyclades in the Aegean. And there do seem to be, to the untrained eye, to my untrained eye, there do seem to be similarities.
能够繁荣然后消失。好吧，所以最后一件事情是，研究这个领域的两个主要人物，也就是米拉耶瓦西奇和玛丽亚·金巴塔斯，这是该领域的两个顶级名字。他们两个都完全敏锐地察觉到，这种文化的某些东西最终在米诺斯文明中得到了表达，而他们横扫了温查文明，这一切都被抹去了。她的论点是，这些痕迹在爱琴海的岛屿上存活了下来。所以在克里特岛，在爱琴海的基克拉泽斯群岛。对于外行来说，对于我这个外行来说，似乎确实有相似之处。
And obviously, these two great figures involved in the study of this culture sense that as well yeah you know and they spent a lifetime studying it so not a week who am i to sneer at it uh yeah so i think there is something mysterious there god what a fascinating story you know if there are scholars listening to this who are specialists in it let us know what you think i told my i sincerely hope there haven't been scholars specialists in it um one specialist in it. Can you visit it? Can you go and see? Is there a museum in Serbia?
显然，参与研究这种文化的这两位伟大人物也能感受到这一点，是的，你知道的，他们花了一生时间来研究它，而不是一个星期，我算什么东西去嘲笑它，呃，是的，所以我认为那里确实有一些神秘的东西，天哪，多么迷人的故事，你知道，如果听这个的学者中有这方面的专家，让我们知道你的想法，我真诚地希望没有这方面的学者，有一个专家。你能去参观吗？你能去看看吗？塞尔维亚有博物馆吗？
Yeah, there are. Yeah. Gosh, we should do a Rest is History Serbian tour. I'm so thrilled that you finally got interested in history. My heart sank. It plummeted like a stone when it turned out you weren't going to do Stefan Dusan. And actually, this was brilliant. I really enjoyed this.
是的，有的。是的。天哪，我们应该做一次“历史其余部分”的塞尔维亚之旅。我很高兴你终于对历史感兴趣了。我的心沉了下去。当发现你不是要做斯特凡·杜尚时，它像石头一样坠落。实际上，这太棒了。我真的很喜欢这个。
Oh, thanks, Dom. I learned a lot. And I love it when we end a podcast by just basically saying we don't know and we'll probably never know. And that sense of the mystery of the past, I think, is really important. And when we're claiming to, as we often do on this podcast, to know everything, we don't really. So it's great to end in the sort of the mists of time. Known unknowns. Yes, known unknowns.
哦，谢谢，多姆。我学到了很多。我喜欢我们在结束播客时基本上说我们不知道，而且可能永远不会知道。对过去神秘感的那种感觉，我认为非常重要。当我们声称，正如我们经常在这个播客中所做的那样，无所不知时，其实我们并非如此。所以很高兴在时间的迷雾中结束。已知的未知。是的，已知的未知。
There you go. I'm all about the mist of time. Tom is all about Donald Rumsfeld. That's the dynamic that has made this podcast beloved by both its listeners. And we'll be back, won't we, Tom, with more World Cup known unknowns next time and that's a known known we'll see you tomorrow bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
给你。我完全是为了时间的迷雾。汤姆完全是为了唐纳德·拉姆斯费尔德。正是这种动力让这个播客深受听众喜爱。我们还会回来的，对吧，汤姆，下次会有更多世界杯的已知未知，这是一个已知的已知，我们明天见，再见，感谢收听“历史其余部分”，获取奖励剧集、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦点缀的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。